[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
bof je suis assez fâché ce soir mon
petit doigt m'a dit qu'il y à beaucoup
d'enfants qui vont se coucher avec les
mains sales au avec l'humain sa wii
nounours et sans se laver les dents sans
se laver le temps tout n'est pas
possible patrons ne sont sûrement pas
nicolas et pimprenelle à j'espère bien
mon échelle je m'en vais voir ça de plus
près c'est que moi je ne vais pas chez
des enfants ou mains sales
hop hop au sort on veut ce sont des
enfants propres
ils nettoient leurs chaussures c'est
très bien ça c'est très amusant que ça
nous regarde
montrozier à quatre fleurs pour le
boulou rosemont au cirque quatre fleurs
d'une charmante aux couleurs quand la
nuit est à l'aider pour le blu-ray jeu
quand la nuit est de l'arrivée mais y'a
trop de faire bombance et de finir 4 et
cognition non 4 champignons non cotre
boutures ont même mois et les haies
messieurs le bouton de rose dans ce tout
les 4 entre eux à joindre merveilleux
comme le sommet y élever le taux de
roseaux c'est la valeur odienné dans la
roue s'élance mais les voies du
barbouillé journée c'est merveilleux
plus chaussures bon j'avais été où ses
propos
regarde un peu les miennes l'ours suite
ma vie ni à présent il faut se laver les
mains
oui il faut
[Musique]
et dès que vous aurez les mains propres
les hauts rangs
holy crois oui oui oui nicolas ne nous a
dit olli oui au lui oui
[Musique]
produit de grands le tout
oui où les bulls
oui oui je vous le livre hoolicool
[Musique]
ce soir dit j
bruit seul le roulis gouly
[Musique]
on lit tous les amis oui oui au lit le
net ou bien sauf
nous vous dit où lé nounours tu le dis
on obéit
on va au lit au lit
[Musique]
famille on nous l'a dit
oubli au libouli au libouli honni
oui oui nounours route niono vous dit on
lit au lit au lit et boloni mais oui
bonne nuit au lit bonne nuit les rangs
les petits bonne nuit les grands les
petits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez comme c'est amusant de se
laver les mains et de faire ça revel
revoir les zoos à demain nicolas n'est
pas preneurs tort bien
[Musique]
j'espère que tous les petits enfants on
suivre le bon exemple de nicolas et de
pimprenelle sans aucun doute pas trop
allons en route le nours bonne nuit des
enfants faites de beaux rêves
à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]